joining us here to to uh to celebrate
this but this could be a good fantasy
team name
celebrate the eberflus
everybody
from good morning football one of our
favorites kyle brandt good to see you
kyle how are you sir
it's great to talk to you rich happy
eber flu stay they're partying in the
streets in chicago
yeah right it's iber flushes day off
right
it's good
um okay i'll get i'll i'll give you the
floor on um the uh the the uh the bears
sticking with a mat swapping out their
naggy for an eberflus your thoughts kyle
brent what do you think
[Music]
i think anybody is i'm missing a card's
on the table rich i think anybody is
being disingenuous if they're saying
oh yeah this is great and i know
sometimes you've talked about this on
the show that people's the pitch of
their voice will elevate if they're not
being totally true higher register yes
yeah i'm hearing a lot of oh that's good
i like it
people are going way up into the upper
octave
you look at
the chicago bears right i mean this is i
think it's the prestigious premier
franchise the guy's never been a head
coach okay never on any level and you
just look at that that sweet sweet
beautiful number one justin fields and
you just want something to to cradle him
and protect him and and and nurture him
and we got a a defensive coach so
i i was looking for one of these guys
these these dables and there are these
hackets who are just they're vouched for
by all pro quarterbacks like oh this is
my guy this is my guy so i i have to i
have to tell you i'm i'm a little bit
surprised i guess i'm not surprised that
the bears do it i'm more a little bit
let down as a bears fan and i'm trying
what are we going with here rich help me
out e b e r
l
is that is that what it is it is that's
the eber and the flues together um yeah
i think that that the great paulie pabst
has said it it sounds like a dutch music
festival yeah going to ebreflus with my
friends this weekend so that's where
that's where we got backstage passes the
eberflues well i guess you know i guess
darius leonard could could vouch for him
which would you know which is great
um the defense was terrific this year
but
uh nobody thought at all that the
defense was the issue or has been the
issue or will be the issue in chicago
the issue is protecting the kid
and not just protecting him by getting
ryan foles to get the right guy
to um
pardon me ryan polls to get the right
guy to write
people to keep
fields upright but to protect him with a
scheme and somebody who's got a plan and
so i don't i don't i need to wait to see
who the offensive person is right
because for all we know even flues could
be
you know nick ciriani was watering and
fertilizing his way to a playoff season
you know what i mean so we we don't know
i guess is another way to look at it and
richie we're right there they did also
have a foals last year though they
didn't need this that's really
superfluous um
you know what i think though yes
this is the true bear fan this is this
this is gonna come out okay i don't care
if it's matt naggy or matt eber fluse or
matt leblanc or matt dylan i don't care
i the the path to victory is the path by
which number 12 for the green bay
packers gets the hell out of the nfc
north because i don't care who's
coaching the bears
they beat them year after year if that
guy is there and i think they may get
both so eber flew great
rogers leaving hackett signing his new
coach somewhere else that's the real
good news for bears today kyle brandt
here on the rich eisen show ten
questions with kyle brandt here uh
sebastian maniscalco uh ten questions
with kyle just dropped uh where all
podcasts can be acquired so um
roger's going we just had jay glazer in
studio and he's like the other day i
thought he's gone now if you ask me i
think he's gonna stay so i guess we've
just entered that portion of
of the non-playing season where we're
trying to figure all that out but we did
have we did play this sound bite uh from
uh 2020
um
to start the show today where where
rogers talked about nathaniel hackett
you know uh actually let's play that for
kyle
go ahead here it is hack has been uh a
really important part of our culture
change
and a part of
our success on offense i love him hope
he doesn't go anywhere
unless i do
there you go now here we are smash cut
to january 2022 and hack it does go
somewhere so you think this really does
happen you really think so kyle
here's what i think i i think the one
thing i feel most positive about is that
rogers is not going to retire i i really
don't think that's going to happen i
think you know i i've even spoken to
about it quite a while ago he he that's
not on the table he's he's still the
best player in the league he loves
football for all the things that get
this in the way of that and in the media
he loves playing football he's the best
player in the league i also think he
more than any athlete in the world when
he talks about football is very
selective in what he says i don't think
that bite you just played is him being
cute or glib i think that's being put
out there i wouldn't put it past him
rich i mean this
i wouldn't put it past either hackett or
rogers rogers the ultimate strategist in
the football world to have known this is
a thing for a while to know to know that
nate is leaving after this year and if
he goes i go and i know this is the last
dance at that last dance thing it was
fun and we all talked about it when they
tweeted it and instagram at the
beginning of the year i also don't think
that was a joke i also don't think that
was just them being cute and grabbing
the pop culture thing i i really do
think that it's been known for a long
time in aaron rodgers head that he's not
coming back to green bay so now that
he's got his best buddy a guy who can
actually tolerate him because as much as
we love roger
that can't be easy man i mean that
cannot be an easy guy to coach to meet
with year after year to just start
afresh with some coach he doesn't have a
relationship with it seems
pretty close to turnkey with the coach
he loves with the good defense and on
and on and on receivers you know the the
accoutrements there i i i buy into it
and i i get a kick out of denver this
morning we had it on our show and mike
are followers reporting and i'm sure the
report is completely accurate and i
trust it then we're putting that message
out there we love coach hackett in and
of himself has nothing to do with aaron
nothing at all that i get it i get it
but if you're gonna bring in uh
solange now to record an album
maybe there's a shot her sister might
come along for the recorder tracker too
i think it's kind of the elephant in the
room
oh
yeah you're hoping you know just maybe
you know although so so um
hack it's the solange right of this i
think it's the salon and rich i'm
following the news cycle
let me get this straight dan quinn is
the proverbial front runner to be the
broncos head coach
oh three days ago yes and then are you
telling me that the packers then lose
that home a game in which they score 10
points and oh my gosh never mind dan
quinn all of a sudden let's take this
coach has nothing to do with the mvp
quarterback who definitely wants to
leave and just played miserable and has
to get the hell out of there but we love
hackett has nothing to do that is a
thick viscous coincidence
[Music]
does not belong on our list of fantasy
team names chris that is that that that
is an inappropriate spot because this
should be the name of a hall of fame
rock band or mockumentary band
right thick ladies viscous coincidence
put your hands together wow
writers in the air the jam band they
play for hours the same song is that
what it is
it's like the string cheese
incident they tour with string cheese
and so they just play forever it feels
like one song
everybody's in a different planet they
opened for karmazi group thing that's
what they they opened up for karmazi
group think yep that's what they did
that's had uh fantastic thick you know
what but hackett killed the interview
you know
he killed the interview he did
apparently
you know couldn't let him out of the
building and how about the fact that
schefter says the jaguars team plane was
there to take
vic fangio down to see if he could be
their fit
for head coaching that that's what he
said oh my gosh well that would be
definitely the anti-urban meyer like
all the things that urban day i don't
think vic is doing that at the happy
hour and the kick and the kickers like
that would be the classic zag to the zig
there'll be no twitter video of vic
fangio at happy hours
with the co-ed none of that i don't
think vic is going to be throwing back
mudslides at the tgi fridays maybe he's
probably going to be at home uh painting
tiny soldiers under a magnifying glass
and watching defensive tape
he'll just vic the kicker that's it
that's what they're going to do they're
getting vicking the kicker uh kyle brown
here on the rich eisen show how do you
see championship sunday playing out kyle
what do you think
um what do you think here
patrick holmes has never lost the
playoff game to anybody but tom brady
and that's very compelling very
compelling and yet
it's not just that the bengals beat them
rich it's they beat them about 20
minutes ago this was not one of these
things back in october september
and there's only been let's see patrick
mahomes has 20 and three in games where
they don't turn the ball over
didn't turn the ball over against the
bengals just got
out shot they did basically the josh
allen thing except
joe burrow one i have a little uh my
left pinky starts to tingle when i start
to feel an upset alert and i'm not
afraid to say it that i got a little
tingle going on right now about the afc
and i know that's awesomeness and it's
mahomes conference and the afc title
game is officially the arrowhead
invitational every single year i like
the bengal squad
really isn't it well you know what uh
like on the money line no stop it no
don't don't excuse me
you know what that means stop it just
because the nfl network told you
no more does not mean you should
disrespect kyle brent i was just looking
for tip i understand that uh don't
disrespect me no he's no longer part of
nfl network he doesn't have to he
doesn't have to worry about that anymore
okay so um
but
here's the thing with borrow
the thing with burrow is we just don't
know
if we're about to see
the all-time great ascension right
that
on on a day that big ben retires and he
was the youngest quarterback to win the
super bowl and the
only one to do it right in year two
that that we could see this again
because we just don't know if the
borough that smoked cigars in the bayou
and put a ring on his finger is that kid
for cincinnati and nobody could say it's
not possible at all
it's that that's the thing that
fascinates me about barry we could be
seeing history
um that's possible oh he's not only a
lot of quarterbacks they're cool
he is almost strangely cool like i i his
pulse should he be on some kind of watch
list or something like he's like a
dexter type of flat pulse
in which like come on now are you
telling me after the eighth sack against
the bleeping titans that he couldn't
even yell at one lineman or throw one
mouth guard he's doing nothing at best
he gets he starts short arm and throws
at worst he's like i'm out of here this
is stupid they told me i should have
boycotted the draft and not gone to
cincinnati he did none of that stuff
nine sacks he doesn't give a damn it's
an almost eerie
watch list type cool that he has and you
gotta respect it is true so before i let
you go what about the nfc does uh
shanahan
do it for a seventh straight time it's
crazy six-game win streak against the
rams including a week 18 where they did
the undertaker jimmy g the undertaker
move
uh where the rams had their best shot
to get the um
to get the niners out and the saints in
who knows right what a sliding door that
is dallas could be in still green bay
could be still in there sean payton
might have found a new life you never
know but uh what do you think about the
nfc championship game before i let you
go back in washington uh sean mcvay
was kyle shanahan's quality control
coach now what does that mean it means
he's basically his assistant and his
gopher and he has talked about it he
actually had the duty one day when he
had to watch the weather and if it was
going to rain that day shawn mcveigh had
to laminate kyle shanahan's play cards
for him laminate it properly and if it's
not laminated you're fired i still think
there's the dynamic here
where he is shanahan's quality control
coach and as much as i love mcveigh and
everything he's accomplished oh my god
it looks great
six in a row is six in a row and the
problem with shannon this now becomes
the the conversation about sean mcvay it
used to be he's never blown a half-time
lead he's the future of coaching he's
the wonder boy and maybe he is
not against his coach he's still
laminating that play sheet every single
time he's got better talent he's home
sort of at home but i just the niners
could not give less of a bleep about any
of that and the debo thing and it's just
they seem to have all the momentum and i
don't care about garoppolo garoppolo
because me one of the coolest stories
we've ever seen where he was kneecapped
by his own team
and
could go to the second straight super
bowl jimmy garoppolo is about to be in
more super bowls than dan marino and
aaron rodgers
kyle brandt choosing both road teams
where the niners make it and then the
bengals make it for a third time in
their team history and they see the
49ers for a third time and they're like
oh my god again the same team but at
least montana is not there that would be
amazing
i will see you on sunday right you're
part of the six hour extravaganza on nfl
game day morning richard could not be
more excited i've never been to the
facility there i've never joined you
guys live apparently myself and the
great michael irvin will be having a
rematch of our hype man showdown
i'm ready i'm going to unleash hell on
him
and um i think last time in the voting
of that hype man showdown the books were
cooked a little bit for the home team so
i'm going to have to really bury him if
i could well you were on remote you were
on remote uh this time you will be in
person um i've been told there's a
surprise celebrity judge for this
yes this is what i've been told um and
it's six hours long it started 30
seconds ago unfortunately we're both
late for it but you've got good morning
football first and i will see you sunday
in the meantime 10 questions with kyle
brandt great podcast world podcast
required the great
kyle bryant thank you sir appreciate you
the best thanks for having me right back
at you kyle brown everybody hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here